there is stunning footage that has been
leaked from the archives of NBC News of
Donald Trump hanging out with accused
serial rapist Jeffrey Epstein in 1992
talking to Epstein about a gaggle of
young women who were dancing in front of
them at a private party so we need to
end this world in which the Trump is
right is allowed to weave what is a
complete fantasy world that it's simply
unbelievable that Donald Trump could
have at any point been involved in any
kind of sexual assault with Jeffrey
Epstein or at Jeffrey Epstein s
Manhattan condo because they barely knew
each other they weren't friends Trump
never liked him it needs to stop okay
and corporate media by the way needs to
stop giving any benefit of the doubt to
that narrative that Donald Trump has
been trying to weave Donald Trump to
catch you up was accused of raping a 13
year old girl that also claims Jeffrey
Epstein raped her and that the suit was
ultimately pulled because of alleged
death threats against the 13 year old
the then 13 year old Donald Trump's
outgoing labor secretary Alexander
Acosta gave Jeffrey Epstein a
ridiculously good plea deal years ago
and he now has been forced to resign as
a result of it Donald Trump has claimed
time and again he never liked Jeffrey
Epstein never was really a fan never
really hung out with Jeffrey Epstein
barely knew the guy and this every
single day is a narrative that is being
absolutely destroyed by facts and
evidence there's now newly discovered
footage from the NBC archives which
shows that Donald Trump was not only
talking to Jeffrey Epstein after warmly
welcoming him to his party in 1992 he
was clearly talking on video about the
young women that were dancing in front
of them who's hot whispering sweet
nothings into Jeffrey Epstein's
ear about who knows what it is that
maybe Jeffrey Epstein might be
interested in doing later on at that
party so this is video from well before
the sickening plea deal that Epstein
ultimately struck in Florida let's take
a look at the video yet a tape
in the NBC archives of a Marla go party
shows Trump giving Epstein his personal
attention the footage shot in November
of 1992 before Trump opened the resort
of the club shows the future president
surrounded by cheerleaders for the
Buffalo Bills and Miami Dolphins
capturing Trump's fun-loving bachelor
lifestyle for an appearance on faith
Daniels NBC talk show me to get great
ratings in your show Trump is surrounded
by women as music blares in the
background after a while Trump goes to
greet three new guests among them the
financier Jeffrey Epstein more than a
decade before his guilty plea on state
prostitution charges later in the
footage Trump is seen talking to Epstein
and another man as women are dancing in
front of them Trump alternates between
dancing and pointing out women too
Epstein and the other man and telling
Epstein about the cameras though exactly
what they say is difficult to understand
as they discuss the women and their
appearances Trump gestures to one and
appears to say to Epstein look at her
back there she's hot and then
Trump says something else into Epstein's
ear that makes him double over with
laughter but as the president says now
he never liked tax to him I was not a
fan of his that I can tell you I was not
a fan of his so this is actually even
worse than previously imagined I hope
you noticed by the way if you were
watching the video if not find the audio
find the video because the audio doesn't
do it justice
Trump at one point grabbing a woman's
rear end in the video that's a really
nice touch so Trump is said I barely
knew the guy seems to know I'm pretty
well based on this video all of the
prior reporting on this has been
accurate Trump was friends with Epstein
Trump was accused of raping a 13 year
old in Epstein's Manhattan apartment but
the picture is now sort of expanding to
show this as a two-way relationship
which is what quite frankly most of us
believed it to be most of us in the side
of logic and reason believed it to be
from the beginning of the evidence that
we started gathering on this issue not
only was Epstein possibly facilitating
trysts for Donald Trump at Epstein's
homes going back to the 90s Trump was
potentially facilitating trysts for
Epstein at Trump's own properties
especially remember we heard early this
week or late last week about the party
planner who is told to gather 28 young
women for a party which would be
attended only by those 28 young women as
well as Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein
so consider how much we have to suspend
disbelief in order to believe the right
wing talking points on this Trump now he
didn't like Epstein well we've got
footage where they certainly seemed to
like each other Trump now he didn't go
to parties with young girls along with
Epstein except now there's video of
Epstein going to Trump's parties with
young women why is it so difficult to
imagine that sometimes the parties would
be at Epstein's place as well
their relationship oh it was distant
they were definitely not bonding over
women they found attractive oh wait now
there's video of Trump and Epstein
gawking at women dancing while Donald
from discusses with Epstein which ones
are attractive and how attractive are
they Trump is on video
saying you just do what you want when
you're famous grab him by the [ __ ] and
then in the video that is uncovered by
NBC he is literally grabbing a woman's
rear end without it being clear if that
what she wants to have happen but we're
supposed to believe that it's all
unsubstantiated attack rumors meant to
make Donald Trump look bad remember
there were no such allegations against
Barack Obama another Democratic
president president there were no such
allegations against George W Bush a
Republican president this is not just
par for the course where every president
is not only accused of a dozen sexual
assaults but there's video evidence of
them in cahoots with individuals with
whom they allegedly conspired on some of
these sexual assaults it's all on video
the grab him by the [ __ ] tape now this
video court documents from multiple
women including Trump's own ex-wife
saying he raped me he assaulted me but
we have to pretend like idiots oh we
don't know there's no real evidence will
there ever be responsibility for having
elected a serial sex assault or to the
presidency not if Trump assay and
increasingly you know impeachment would
take a while
removal by the 25th amendment would take
a while actual consequences for all of
these alleged sexual assaults by Donald
Trump may never happen but we can remove
the guy in November in 2020 and in
November of 2020 and I hope that we do
do that let me know what you think about
this latest video I'm on twitter at D
Pakman if you're not following me on
Twitter please follow me on Twitter had
an interesting little exchange this
morning actually with Dave Rubin that
you can see there also while you're on
Twitter you might as well follow at
David Pakman show as well one of today's
sponsors is impeach the card slap game
you can't slap Donald Trump in real life
but you can slap them in this hilarious
fast-paced two-player card game and you
can get it for ten percent off when you
go to david pakman.com slash impeach
impeach the card game is awesome for
parties or when you're having a few
drinks I've been playing it with some
friends of mine it combines clever
satire about the Trump administration
with really funny high-quality cartoon
artwork all in a very lively card game
that's easy to learn but it stays
interesting every time you play it
because of how well designed it is and
how much thought went into the humor and
the political commentary impeach the
cards slap game is perfect
if you're looking for something fun and
casual to do with your politically
minded friends or family members it'll
make a perfect gift for anyone you know
who has a sense of humor about Donald
Trump and when you go to david
pakman.com slash impeach not only will
you get 10% off the game you can also
get 10% off all of the other hilarious
clothing and accessories in their online
store t-shirts coffee mugs tote bags
featuring funny political cartoons about
trump that you can't find anywhere else
get a super fun witty gift for yourself
or someone you know whether it's impeach
the card slap game or anything else in
the gift shop
and get 10% off all of it when you go to
david pakman.com slash impeach